and get 2 months free.
>> WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO
JAMES COMEY?
>> President Trump: I WOULD
SAY HOW IS HE GOING TO EXPLAIN
TO HIS GRANDCHILDREN ALL THE
LIES, DECEIT AND PROBLEMS HE'S
CAUSED IN THIS COUNTRY?
I THINK THE THINGS I'VE DONE FOR
THIS COUNTRY, THE FIRING OF
JAMES COMEY IS GOING TO GO DOWN
AS A GOOD THING.
THE FBI IS GREAT, I KNOW SO MANY
PEOPLE IN THE FBI AND IT'S A
FANTASTIC INSTITUTION.
BUT SOME OF THE PEOPLE AT THE
TOP FOR ROTTEN APPLES, JAMES
COMEY WAS ONE OF THEM.
I HAVE DONE GREAT SERVICE TO
THIS COUNTRY BY GETTING RID OF
HIM AND FIRING HIM.
>> SO YOU HAVE NO PROBLEM
EXPLAINING THIS TO YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN?
>> President Trump: NO.
THE ONE THAT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP
TALKING ABOUT JAMES COMEY.
JOINING US NOW IS SEBASTIAN
GORKA, DAN BONGINO, AND
TAMMY BRUCE.
THE THREE OF YOU ARE GREAT
GUESTS, WE LOVE HAVING YOU ON.
BUT I WILL START WITH YOU,
BECAUSE WOMEN BEFORE MEN, YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT GUY IS.
SO WHY IS IT TAKING SO LONG TO
GET THE INFORMATION THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO GET?
>> THEY ARE STONEWALLING
EVERYONE.
THAT'S WHY YOU DON'T HAND OVER
SOMETHING WHEN YOU WERE SUPPOSED
TO HAVE MORALLY SUPERIOR
FRAMEWORK.
LET'S REMEMBER THE PRESIDENT IS
THERE, IT'S VERY COMFORTABLE,
IT'S OBVIOUS.
INCLUDING ONE OF THE EARLIEST
ONES WERE HE DECLARED THAT HIS
CAMPAIGN WAS BEING SPIED ON.
HE WAS MOCKED, RIDICULED AND
CLEARLY NOTE THAT NOW THAT HAS
BEEN CONFIRMED.
SO PEOPLE ARE UNDERESTIMATING
THE PRESIDENT, AND HE SAID
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, AND YOU
SHOULD BELIEVE HIM.
AND HE IS CORRECT.
ESSENTIALLY THE LEAKING OF
MATERIAL THAT HE WROTE DOWN WITH
MEETINGS WITH THE PRESIDENT, ALL
OF THESE THINGS INDICATE A MAN
WHO HAD PROBLEMS.
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT JOE
DIGENOVA HAS NOTED THAT THERE
ARE INDIVIDUALS IN THE FBI WHO
WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
ON AT THE FBI, AND THEY NEED TO
BE SUBPOENAED SO THEY HAVE
PROTECTIONS AGAINST THE AGENCY.
AND CONGRESS WILL PAY THEIR
LEGAL BILL.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING OF
WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
>> Judge: SO SEBASTIAN GORKA,
CAN THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF BE
CLASSIFYING SOME OF THE
INFORMATION WE ARE TRYING TO GET
AND WILL THAT SHORT-CIRCUIT THE
WHOLE THING?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HE HAS CLASSIFICATION AUTHORITY,
AND UNIQUELY HIS OWN
ADJUDICATING AGENCY AS WELL.
WHAT HE NEEDS TO DO IS ORDER THE
DECLASSIFICATION OF EVERY
DOCUMENT RELATING TO THE
CROSS FIRE HURRICANE OPERATION
WHICH IS POLITICAL ESPIONAGE
AGAINST ANOTHER PARTY'S
CANDIDATE.
AND ON TOP OF THAT, THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT HE CAN DO
RIGHT NOW AT THE STROKE OF A
PAN-COMPANY NEEDS TO PULL THE
CLEARANCES OF CLAPPER, COMEY,
BRENNAN AND HILLARY.
WHAT ARE THESE PEOPLE DOING
MAKING COMMENTS ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION WITH CLEARANCES AND
PICKING UP PAYCHECKS?
>> Judge: IF THESE PEOPLE ARE
NOT IN OFFICE ANYMORE AND HE
STILL HAD SECURITY CLEARANCES?
IS THAT FOR EVERYONE?
WHAT ARE THESE PEOPLE DOING WITH
CLEARANCES?
IS THERE A REQUIREMENT FOR A
REGULATION?
>> IT'S JUST A REGULATION.
>> Judge: SO TAKE THEIR
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
>> JUDGE, JIM TOLD ME HE IS IN A
WORLD OF TROUBLE.
HE HAS YET TO EXPLAIN WHAT I'M
CALLING PARAGRAPH ONE.
WHAT DO I MEAN BY THAT?
WHEN I WAS A SECRET SERVICE
AGENT I WROTE A CASE REPORT ON A
CASE IN PARAGRAPH ONE SET HOW
THAT CASE STARTED.
I RECEIVED A CALL ABOUT A STOLEN
CREDIT CARD, WHATEVER IT IS.
NO ONE HAS GIVEN US PARAGRAPH
ONE ON WHY THEY STARTED A
INTELLIGENCE INVESTIGATION
AGAINST TRUMP.
POINT NUMBER TWO, THERE ARE
FOUNDING LEAKS IN THIS CASE.
THERE WAS A LEAK TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ABOUT THE
EXISTENCE OF THE CASE BEFORE
THEY CLOSED IT, AND A WEAK
STOMACH CLICK TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION BY MIKE FLYNN.
THAT'S WHY I BELIEVE THEY ARE
NOT THE CLASSIFYING OF A THING
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A SERIOUS
FELONY CASE AGAINST THE LEAKERS.
>> I THINK THE IRONY OF THIS IS
THEY THOUGHT THIS RUSSIAN
COMPLAINT WOULD BRING DOWN TRUMP
AND WHAT IT HAS DONE IS UNLOCKED
THE DOORS TO SHOW US A LEVEL OF
CORRUPTION THAT NONE OF US COULD
HAVE IMAGINED.
AND AGAIN, THIS IS THE RIGHT MAN
IF ANYONE HAS THE DISCIPLINE TO
SEE IT THROUGH TO FACE THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD AN ENORMOUS
WORLDWIDE POWER, IT'S
DONALD TRUMP.
SO THIS IS THE MAN NOT JUST OF
THE HOUR ABOUT A MAN OF FATE,
AND THIS IS THE TIME WHERE WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO GET THIS
DONE.
IT'S BEING HANDED TO US.
AND THIS IS NONPARTISAN, EVERY
INDIVIDUAL HAS TO CARE
REGARDLESS OF YOUR PARTY
REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU THINK OF
THE PRESIDENT.
>> Judge: SEBASTIAN, I ONLY
HAVE 15 SECONDS LEFT.
IF THIS IS THE CASE AND IF THIS
THING WAS STARTED AND THEY HAVE
LIED -- WHILE I'M NOT GOING TO
SAY THEY'VE LIED BUT THEY HAVE
SO MANY DIFFERENT STARTING
POINTS.
FIRST IT WAS JULY, THEN IT WAS
SPRING.
WHEN WILL THIS BE OVER?
WILL THEY TRY TO GET IN IN
NOVEMBER AND APPEASE THE
PRESIDENT?
>> I THINK ROBERT MUELLER WILL
TRY TO DROP A REPORT THAT WILL
BE USED AS A POLITICAL WEAPON IN
BE USED AS A POLITICAL WEAPON II
THE MIDTERM, ABSOLUTELY.